life is a mess there are all kinds of
forms of life on this planet and anytime
you want to do anything scientific it's
good to have some kind of organizing
principle biologists use a very rough
organizing principle for defining types
of life by calling them species species
traditionally was the distinction of
different animals or different forms of
life which cannot interbreed or even if
they do interbreed their offspring
cannot reproduce this is a rough
definition of course but it was useful
in categorizing and and enumerated the
number of types of forms of life on
Earth there are and now that that list
is in the millions we have a very
complicated web of what the Tree of Life
looks like but even more interesting is
that the ability to access the genetic
information of different species had
allowed biologists to see where the
lines are blurred between two different
types or more species what they found
was interesting first that species there
are many species which inner breed they
have sex with each other and they
produce offspring and a lot of genetic
information is shared between species
but what they've also found is that
their genetic distinguishing features
that remain robust it's like if you have
two cans of paint and you pour them into
each other say one yellow and one red
and you mix it all up and it all turns
orange except for these spots some are
exactly red and the other ones are
yellow and they don't blend for some
reason parts of the DNA which stay
robustly distinct between two species
one example is in northern Europe there
are two different species of crows the
carrion
and the hooded crow and yet they do in
her breed and they do live
geographically in overlapping places and
yet their distinguishing features remain
in fact their genetic codes are so
similar that you looking at the DNA
would never call them different species
and yet they look completely different
and therefore are easily distinguished
and the question is why why is it so
robust and we don't know and so studying
the genomes and great details of
neighboring species and lots of
different species we can understand what
we mean by the word species at all